The main video is currently using a little trick.
The rate that advertisers pay per 1000 views is actually a lot higher ...
... and if you have a YouTube channel you can watch your analytics and see a song ...
... that is much larger per 1000.
This is because there are a number of YouTube viewings where no advertisement is displayed.
If you find that hard to believe, it's probably because you ...
... is in a main target group that advertisers want, so you always get ads on YouTube.
But there are demographics that rarely see advertisements.
In addition, YouTube does not show advertisements for people arriving on the site for the first time.
Channels can have 30%, 40%, up to 90% of their viewings without an advertisement ...
... to play, because there are viewers who are in a time or location that fewer advertisers want.
Or, fewer advertisers can be present.
But if you make a YouTube channel, then the number you are really worried about ...
... the one on your check, divided by your thousands of viewings.
This is the number that video makers compare with each other,
even though YouTube doesn't really want us to do that.